[Music]
look man it's always been propaganda but
at least used to be funny you know what
I mean sometimes I've been going down
this crazy rabbit hole with this
comedian guy I don't know if you heard
but he had a Carson thing this guy I
don't even want to get into it because I
sound like an absolute lunatic talking
about it Brendan chop no no no no
they're not way worse than bending shot
whoa now I need to know yes I'm just I'm
just gonna say no I don't care have you
guys ever heard of a man named Peter
shickley
Peter shickley how do you spell that
s-c-h-i-c
-k-e-l-e okay Peter shickley I had never
heard of him either I asked I had
someone I saw I was at the Stan Comedy
Club last week Andrew Dice Clay was
there okay so let me just give you a
preface and I sound like a lunatic
because this is all I can talk about for
the last like two weeks this guy won
best comedy album at the Grammys in 1990
1991 1992 and 1993 he went four in a row
okay Jesus he beat nobody has ever heard
of him
Andrew Dice Clay only time he's ever
been nominated in 1990 for his album
dice he was the biggest comedian in the
world okay he was at the stand last
Friday for his birthday party this guy
last Thursday this guy right here okay
we go and I've asked everybody nobody's
ever heard of him okay we go ask dice we
go dice this guy beat you because I'm
like I'm like I have to make a
documentary about this or something it's
just so crazy go dice you know this guy
is he goes never heard of him Nobody
Knows the guy who loves the Grammys
watch what was the best comedy in the
world for four years okay okay I would
love this okay let's see uh here we go
for four years you say okay four years
in a row hey
what is
so wait the joke is that the music's not
matching no they're so the the Johnny
Carson's band is playing over him right
but this is an 87 this is not what he
won for what he won for so this guy if
you go look up his bio there's it's
something really fishy going on here
okay because if you look up his bio he's
a professor he's a composer he's like a
classical composer he like went to
Juilliard nowhere in any of his [ __ ]
does he say that he won four comedy
Grammys in a row like he doesn't even
talk about it he's like embarrassed
about it or he just like doesn't bring
it up he's still alive he lives in New
York I'm trying to like interview him
because I'm like I gotta get to the
bottom of this he beat George Carlin
[ __ ] uh Sam Kinison dice he beat
Weird Al you know the Weird Al here with
the Nirvana cover yeah yeah he beat him
for that and he's literally if you
listen to his albums it's just classical
music he does some physical gags which
if you do physical gags why would you
win best comedy album makes zero sense
bro it's so funny because I Googled his
name and then Grammy and then like you
you know you on blind my blind mic
project talking about it was like the
number four that's how it came that's
how it came up because I heard of it I
just had blind Mike on the show today to
my day wave show today that's pretty
funny yeah that's like it just randomly
so wait that is weird though you win
four Grammys right
like that would be all you'd [ __ ]
talk about but nobody no you would be a
absolute like you would be selling out
theaters you would be like a household
name yeah comedy and the year before he
won his first one
was Robin Williams and the year after he
won his last one was uh George Carlin so
he's not likely the Grammys went in a
different direction
dude this is so weird oh man one of the
you know what's gonna happen Danny
someone's gonna steal this from you make
a [ __ ] Netflix documentary on it
you'll be like it'll be called something
like who's Peter schlecki or whatever
chickadee whatever who who's Peter
chickley or whatever you know or find um
finding chickley let me see if I can
send it to you really funny is this is
this this guy's a weird dude huh
he's he's just a composer he's a
classical composer that's all he is but
then why were you in comedy album
look I will concede that he could win
one okay maybe that year was like a bad
year right
before in a row also those four years
were the four years that the Buffalo
Bills lost the Super Bowl ah not trying
to be a conspiracy no no you know what
this is yeah I don't care if YouTube
Kicks us off I'm doing this conspiracy
right now it will kick us off I think
Danny has stumbled on a clear case of
like the CIA is like memory hauling and
rewriting history like the Berenstain
Bears thing yeah they're editing
Wikipedia they're just out they're
[ __ ] spreading disinforcement I just
this is like something that uh let me
check this is like Mandela effect type
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] we're being
programmed into things in Israel
because Danny's freaking out because
he's like wait no something's wrong this
is something's not working he's wrong
the fact that dice was like I've never
heard of him
that's when the [ __ ] Grammys was
important like it's like a joke because
somebody made this for you this is
hilarious
yeah in Canada stolen stolen laughter I
love the name oh my God that's very
funny when you first sent that it looked
real I was like oh they really did one
nope but that's it's gonna happen no no
he made it I need to know about this I
need to know more about it honestly dude
there's so little information okay I
messaged this guy
um so I was I've been like actually
doing real research on this [ __ ] I
messaged this guy uh who because I went
and looked up Peter shickley on Twitter
he has like a barely dude he has 300
followers on Instagram wow so he has
okay he has like maybe a couple thousand
on Twitter so I find him and then he had
a birthday post and someone replied to
it it's like a verified guy so I'm like
you know I'm gonna message this guy and
it was uh David Silverman who is who
directed and I'm like he followed me
actually for some reason I don't know
why so then I started talking with him
he's the directed The Simpsons Movie
really
animator on The Simpsons since 1987.
he's like he's like OG like he like
invented essentially animating Homer
Simpson right can I DM him I go like yo
I got to know about this thing like why
did this guy win he goes like I have no
idea he's like he's a great guy he was
doing this classical music parody stuff
it was funny but he's like I'm really
into classical music so that's why like
people who are into classical music
right so his bit is called PDQ Bach
that's like what won four in a row it's
the same thing every year too it's the
same like shtick
it's not I I can't impress enough that
it's not comedy it's classical music
[Applause]
is it is it in this is it in this clip
well that he so yes he gets on the couch
though what does he talk like oh here it
is PDQ Buck I got it yeah okay let's see
PDQ like just lit but just make sure
that you realize that he won best album
okay so this is purely on a listening
experience all right so this should be
the best comedy listening
[Music]
all right
wow man that's crazy honestly I'm losing
my mind this is gonna set me to the
[ __ ] mental facility honestly I
wonder if this is like like maybe
because it's this is what 87 so you're
talking there was a lot of like
but he won he didn't get he didn't get
nominated until 1990 and he got
nominated 90 91. go go pull up the
Grammys Wikipedia for a comedy album and
see who he was up against like see the
type of people Robin Williams Weird Al
died no he'd never be Robin Williams but
he beat George Carlin he beat Sam
Kinison he dies when dice was the
biggest comedian in the world kinnison
and dice is [ __ ] wild he beat Jackie
Mason which whatever he beat Jonathan
Winters twice he beat Weird Al that
weirdo album sold two million saying a
lot of older people were alive at that
time and I'm wondering if it was just
because everything was safer back then
he was probably but he went back to
George Carlin like he after his four
consecutive wins wow he went back look
at who won before him and after yeah
best comedy reading about the guy this
is literally comedy made for like three
people
yes it's very neat it seems like very
Niche Comes The Comedy the the comedy is
actually coming from him taking like
using bagpipes instead of like a bassoon
on like a box song like it's so nice but
like it's like haha I used a kazoo in a
[ __ ] classical piece it's like what
the [ __ ] well guys like I'm if it was
one of them honestly if he won once I
would been like whatever week class that
year they're the Grammy it happened in a
certain way yeah it happened fine
whatever
that like that you're the magic made the
finals it happened sometimes exactly or
whatever right is the fact that he won
four in a row right is inexplicable
so this is the audiences
Professor so am I yes all right we'll
come back and try to sort that out in
just a second right after this
I notice a little look of puzzlement on
the audience's face apparently they are
not familiar with P Duke uh yeah okay so
Danny's got a point here because here's
the thing merch you're right maybe maybe
old people like say stuff but Carson's
got a point he's like
87 Carson probably had a pretty old and
he didn't get invited back to Carson so
this wasn't like his first of seven he
got his one Carson I can't even believe
he got called over the couch yeah as
much as you are I have not been able to
find him in any musical dictionaries at
all no I know my research is into PDQ
Bach is a very lonely Affair I've been
kicked out of the AMJ the American Music
illogical Hunter
okay bro how did this guy beat anybody
like I'm not even trying to but again he
doesn't the actual albums yeah it's not
even him talking ever it's just music
and you hear like the odd laugh here and
there but like you're like this guy's
bombing can I say can I just say
something uh Danny I think you're on to
something I don't think I know I know I
don't think you're crazy though because
you're like oh I saw I'm gonna sound
like I'm kind of on your side fascinated
especially after watching this you're
like it's not even like one of those
things to go well I don't find that
funny but I would get why other people
do this is like what Virgie said like
this joke is for like four or five music
Buffs like and again
you most of his comedy like I'm looking
at it comedy comedy I'm sorry you would
have to be a [ __ ] scholar to even
like right get an idea of what he's
talking about wow this is a rabbit hole
but boys it's honestly so nuts like by
the way hey people listening look this
if you find anything send it to us Danny
I'll send it to you right please send it
to me yeah send it to Danny on Twitter
there's honestly almost nothing about
him on the internet like just as just
how crazy it is so his Twitter if you
look him up it's shickly Peter at
chickley Peter his name it says this is
his bio okay he has 427 followers the
official Twitter account of Peter
shickley composer musical satirist radio
host purveyor of Viola jokes do you not
think that your Twitter bio would
mention the fact that you won four
consecutive Grammys for best comedy
album okay can I ask this question now
because I just want to settle this maybe
because everybody's doubting this guy's
genius how many Viola jokes do you have
Danny that's a good point zero I have
nobody I don't even know what a viola is
maybe stuff it's kind of like a violin
but I think it's a big violin right yeah
I think how many times have you played
Symphony Number Nine on a kazoo yeah
the thing too is this guy's 87 years old
so I'm like I got it like clocks taken
for me to go find it you should
interview him but be like I'm trying and
then ask him I need you to punch up my
stuff
[Laughter]
and I mean
if we can uh you can help me out I've
won zero you're a [ __ ] Dynasty
apparently this first question would be
are you classically trained pianist but
can you just go read off who won before
him oh yeah yeah this is like an
operation this is like waking up and
doing the show and like reality has been
[ __ ] so much that now somebody's
coming in and has convinced me that the
Browns won four Super Bowls in a row wow
this is [ __ ] nuts and I'm like I know
for a fact the Browns did not win four
Super Bowls in a row and you're like no
they did all right I'm gonna go down the
list from 1980 on you ready okay 1980
Robin Williams 1981 Rodney Dangerfield
1982 Richard Pryor 83 Richard Pryor
garbage 84 Eddie Murphy 85 Weird Al 86
86.
Whoopi Goldberg not 87 fat
87 Bill Cosby
rapist
formerly alleged okay 88 Robin Williams
89 Robin Williams
1990 1990 our boy Pete 1991 our boy Pete
1992. Petey Boy 1993. Pete again 1994.
George Carlin bro that was such a wild
couple of years for comedy look at this
it's funny you have Robin Williams you
have Robin Williams riding Jr Richard
Pryor and Eddie Murphy fighting back and
forth for this every year this was one
building full of people that lived in
the Upper West Side that were like
any of the other years no that's the
point reasonable picks every other year
four years which make no [ __ ] I'm
telling you Peter shickley was a huge
hit in like one building full of
powerful people in the upper west side
and they all four straight yeah and they
just and they kept making phone calls
and going I don't want to see that
Andrew Dice Clay anywhere in this play
you get me Peter that was the one thing
dice said dice was like I was the
biggest comedian in the world
in the world a Grammy which okay
a point but like there was so many other
like he beat George Carlin
right yeah I mean that again if they're
Upper West Side people like give it to
Jackie Mason or Jonathan Winters
I okay but so far we have that it's
weird but now let's get into the what's
the working conspiracy theory you see
now now we need to get into the to the
news so either he's got some dirt on the
Grammy committee okay right he's like a
CIA operative somebody says I guarantee
you in those powerful pedos maybe he was
the in-house maybe he was Jeffrey
Epstein's in-house pianist oh there he
is
I'm telling you something here is does
not add up you know what's gonna happen
a month from now we're gonna try to get
Danny back on he's gonna be like Pepe
Silva in the Always Sunny episode
oh dude that's like though in my Discord
the low value male Discord that's like
people are literally putting my face on
that being like the red strip that's so
good I love it though but I love this we
we we both we love this thing now he's
[ __ ] now he's got it all like he's
got the stink on us now so now I'm gonna
get assassinated through my window of my
apartment
identity you know I'll just be walking
down the stairwell
but before you die here
oh great I'm gonna get shot by Clive
Owen I need this in my life he's here
kazoo
[Music]